[Música]
hoy 30 de noviembre se conmemora el día
internacional de la lucha contra los
trastornos de la conducta alimentaria
que se identifica bajo el símbolo de un
lazo azul en esta jornada se pretende
visibilizar la importancia de la
prevención y detección de este tipo de
alteraciones alimentarias se trata de
trastornos que generan un comportamiento
compulsivo frente al ingesta de
alimentos y también una obsesión por el
control del peso está presente en todas
las edades sin importar el sexo o la
condición social la causa está
relacionada por múltiples factores
psicológicos o biológicos
socioculturales y también familiares
entre los que sea más conocidos se
encuentran la bulimia la anorexia
nerviosa la autor ex ya el trastorno por
atracón de comida o también la vigorexia
y para ello entonces quiero saludar a
mabel bello y la fundadora y directora
médica de aluba puntal uva que es una
fundación que ayuda a estas personas con
estos trastornos gracias mal por estar
con nosotros en directo américa de
france 4 le preguntó primero entonces
qué es un psa y cómo podemos identificar
lo que sea pero bueno sobre los
trastornos de conducta alimentaria
hay muchos mitos
hay muchas inseguridades y muchas
visiones diferentes en
los trastornos de conducta alimentaria
para nosotros que son una interrupción
en el proceso de maduración y el 40 por
ciento tienen origen genético y el 60%
es por un origen de la cultura la
cultura en donde
se fomenta este el individualismo a
ultranza y evidentemente
la aparición de las imágenes la
televisión las redes sociales estamos
este cautivados por las imágenes y
creemos que estos son los valores
esenciales del ser flaco
una especie de éxito social y realmente
esta condena a las personas que la
padecen al ostracismo oa una vida doble
o realmente a un martirio de estar todo
el tiempo pensando en el cuerpo y la
comida en todas sus formas vigorexia
anorexia bulimia esta
enfermedad por atracón todas las
patologías alimentarias son una forma de
adicción y son un escapismo de la
realidad una persona que tiene
dificultades en lo social o que tiene
dificultades en el control de los
impulsos que son las variantes genéticas
que producen patología alimentaria
sobre todo en la adolescencia y en la y
en la niñez temprana también si existe
la patología en la familia
y se comienza pensando y sintiéndose
gordo aunque uno tenga un peso normal y
después de eso va dejando de comer o si
su plan ismo
presenta un
deseo importante de comer de tener
atracones y después de eso la culpa los
lleva a las conductas negativas
esto está extendido en todo el mundo y
red si realmente este son un flagelo de
la juventud y de la niñez aunque se ven
también en la edad adulta mabel como
cómo poder ayudar a estas personas que
sufren estos trastornos es es como un
digamos que las personas que sufren de
una desea busquen ayuda o sería el
entorno de las familias los que lo
impulsen a tratar de cambiar estas
conductas en el 80% de los casos es la
familia o los amigos que buscan
tratamiento porque como en todas las
adicciones no no hay conciencia
enfermedad escasas veces uno ve a
alguien que se ha asustado porque vomitó
sangre o porque siente que no puede con
sus impulsos y consulta pero mayor parte
de los pacientes viene por indicación
médica o por interés de los padres cómo
se trata estas enfermedades
emocionalmente digamos que es como que
la base principal para poder ayudar a
estas personas y poder salir desde esta
enfermedad
se trata en forma integral la forma de
tratarlo de nuestro equipo es el
paciente ingresa y también ingresa a su
familia el paciente es incluido en un
grupo de autoayuda donde hay un grupo de
chicas que ya ha entendido el fondo de
la patología alimentaria y tiene mucho
interés en salvar a otra paciente que
tiene lo mismo que padecieron ella y el
paciente ingresa al grupo y los padres
ingresan a lo que llamamos entrenamiento
familiar y esto es llevado por padres
que hace muchos años trajeron a sus
hijos y después se quedaron para ayudar
a las familias a entender la parte
social de la enfermedad no es no es muy
raro sino que se siente por ejemplo que
la familia se practique digamos las
dietas
o que haya una idea de adelgazar es lo
más importante si incluso madres jóvenes
este viven que sus hijos en el jardín de
infantes este no coman ni sal ni azúcar
ni coman snacks y realmente esto empieza
a enfermar al chico incluso cuando los
chicos chiquitos si es preescolar es
socializar ya hay gordo flaco y qué
vergüenza y este pretende adelgazar esa
edad de tal manera que esto es la
cultura que tenemos que enferma y la
predisposición de los pacientes por su
genética hace que entren en la patología
mabel muy rápidamente tenemos
aproximadamente un minuto usted hablaba
también de la importancia de la sociedad
la estigmatización de la sociedad cómo
erradicar eso para que no nos seguir
alimentando pues ese trastorno que
tienen estas personas
bueno además de que la familia se trata
y muchas veces se trata médicamente
porque ahí también está la raíz genética
nosotros intervenimos en la sociedad en
las escuelas donde provienen los
pacientes en el trabajo donde damos
charlas explicativas de lo que es la
patología alimentaria y cómo ayudar al
paciente también hacemos prevención en
las escuelas
dando charlas al principio eran sobre
cómo no entrar en la anorexia y bulimia
y cuáles son las personas sensibles para
tener en cuenta para desarrollar dónde
pueden desarrollarse la enfermedad ahora
también damos charlas sobre sobre
patologías sobre otras patologías sobre
otras adicciones porque en las últimas
camadas de pacientes no solo vienen con
anorexia y bulimia sino también con
experiencia de drogas o experiencias de
alcohol y eso también lo tratamos